Chicos, aquí estamos
con Paul Jaimes
para poder juntar firmas y escribir nuestro partido.
Paul, hola, hola, ¡hola! Siempre una patita por delante.
Estamos acá, ¿eh? A la altura de Megaplaza,
tratando de recolectar más firmas
para crear y constituir
el primer partido ecoanimalista
de toda la historia del Perú
y el segundo en el mundo.
En este sentido,
buscamos tener una suciedad más sensible,
que los animalitos,
sea fauna silvestre o nuestras mascotas,
también tenga voz
y que sea parte de una agenda real política
nacionalista animalista
y con ello tengamos una sociedad más sensible.
Listo, chicos, ya saben,
apoyemos a este nuevo partido que estamos creando
siempre en favor de los animales